kuroda seminar pierre meant a Miss June  Sione's vardar yasser VAR dar la  constitución e las leyes y respetar los  derechos de los Tejanos y de las  comunidades all da spain's new king  felipe the 6th took the oath of office  in parliament he swore to uphold  democracy in front of Spanish  legislators the ceremony was low key  because of the economic crisis still  Felipe's ascension to the throne was a  solemn occasion  his father Juan Carlos had abdicated  after nearly three decades his last act  as king was to make his son the head of  the Armed Forces at 46 Felipe is now  Europe's youngest monarch while his wife  letizia is the first commoner queen of  Spain  their elder daughter Leonore on the  right is the new crown princess  Philippe will have to work hard to  restore the monarchy's reputation in the  wake of numerous scandals but he's  promised to Spanish people he will  listen and learn